Die Skeptiker hatten wohl recht.
Mobilfunkfrequenzen verursachen Krebs.
Das ist jetzt bei einer Studie mit Ratten
nachgewiesen worden.
Aber so einfach ist es dann auch nicht, denn
die Wellen haben auch positive Effekte und
das Experiment fand unter ganz besonderen
Bedingungen statt.
Also was ist jetzt Sache?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, dann verpasst ihr kein
Video.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Also was its jetzt Sache.
Also konkretes Ergebnis der Studie: Wenn männliche
Ratten Achtung und jetzt kommen die bestimmten
Bedingungen 1. dauerhaft 2.
mit hohen Dosen 3.
mit bestimmten Mobilfunkwellen bestrahlt werden
dann bekommen sie 4. bestimmte Tumore.
Das betrifft vor allem den Herzmuskel und
das Gehirn.
Und die Frequenzen sind die von UMTS und den
Vorgängern.
Das ist das Ergebnis einer Studie im Auftrag
des Nationalen Toxikologie-Programms der USA.
Damit ist ein direkter Zusammenhang zwischen
Mobilfunkstrahlen und Krebs nachgewiesen worden.
Aber die Forschungsgruppe sagt auch ganz klar,
dass die Stdudie keine Rückschlüsse auf
den Menschen zulässt.
Interessant ist auch, dass weibliche Ratten
gar nicht oder kaum betroffen sind.
Beim Menschen gibt es keine Situation, in
dem es zu dauerhaften Bestrahlung kommt.
Auch die Stärke der Bestrahlung ist in den
meisten Fällen deutlich geringer.
Bei den Versuche wurden die Ratten vier unterschiedlichen
Starhlungsintensitäten ausgesetzt.
Die schwächste entsprach dabei der Stärke,
die maximal für den Menschen zugelassen ist.
Alle anderen Stärken kommen beim Menschen
nicht vor.
Zudem wurden auch positive Auswirkungen der
Bestrahlung festgestellt.
Die Lebenserwartung der Ratten stieg im Schnitt.
Vermutet eine positive Wirkung der Wellen
gegen Nierenversagen, was eine häufige Todesursache
bei Ratten ist.
Jetzt sollen weitere Frequenzen auf diese
Weise untersucht werden wie 5G und WiFi.
Und bei der Untersuchung festgestellte Mutationen
sollen unter die Lupe genommen werden.
Spannend, dass es hier so lange „Funkstille“
gab beziehungsweise immer die Unschädlichkeit
von Mobilfunkwellen betont wurde.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da bei den weiteren
Untersuchungen herauskommt.
Wenn ihr dazu und zu allen anderen Themen
wirklich kein Video verpassen wollt, dann
abonniert auch den englischen Clixoom-Kanal.
Dafür einfach hier klicken.
Auch da gibt es die ein oder andere Videopremiere!
Hier geht es weiter mit: „Ice Age in Europe
- Will the Gulf Stream come to a standstill?“
See you soon - stay tuned!